Nike is keeping its sponsorship of golf
pro Tiger Woods after his arrest in
Florida for driving under the influence
a spokesman told CBS News there is no
change in our relationship with Tiger
the golfer admitted to getting behind
the wheel up to taking a potent mix of
prescription drugs mo Manuel Marquez is
outside Jupiter police headquarters with
new details about woods arrest this week
man well good morning good morning
police reports confirmed that Woods was
not drunk to breathalyzer tests showed
his blood alcohol content was zero but
police say his speech was slurred and he
failed field sobriety tests so they had
to take him into custody around 2:00
Monday morning police say they found
woods asleep behind the wheel of a black
Mercedes like this one his car was
blocking the right-hand lane its left
brake light on and right turn signal
flashing both driver's side tires were
flat the rims were damaged
once awake police say Woods was swaying
that his eyes were extremely droopy and
seemed as if he was lost Woods also told
officers he had taken four medications
including the painkiller vicodin I feel
bad for him golfing inkless said he
hopes Woods will play again he needs a
lot of support from a lot of people and
I'll be one of them Woods who is
recovering from a back operation last
month said I understand the severity of
what I did and I take full
responsibility for my actions
Tiger lucked out he got pulled off the
road before he committed an even worse
crime before he killed somebody for he
injured someone or himself prescription
drugs also allegedly played a role in
woods 2009 crash the latest incidents so
far has not cost him any sponsorships
you can't beat a pack by playing the
same ball as pack Bridgestone golf told
CBS this morning it was continuing to
monitor the situation it saddens you
legal analyst and former 60 Minutes
sports correspondent Jack Ford once
played a round of golf with woods he
says whew DUI cases ever go to trial the
process has become so sophisticated the
testing process so sophisticated and the
penalties are fairly severe so usually
people try to work something out Jupiter
police are expected to release dashcam
video of the arrests later today Woods
received two sight
one for driving under the influence the
other for illegal parking his first
court date is expected to be on July 5th
Nora all right men well thank you